one of the president's main agenda items
as you just heard there
is north korea denuclearization a big
part of that effort is south korean
president
moon jae-in who just wrapped up his own
meeting with chairman kim in north korea
i talked with the south korean president
earlier today
yesterday president trump before the
signing of the new trade agreement
said this a lot of very positive things
are happening with chairman kim
of north korea do you expect another
summit between president trump and
chairman kim
in coming weeks well i would say
yes i traveled to pyongyang last week
and had a very good
meeting with chairman kim and through
the
summit meeting we had achieved some
progress on denuclearization
and i look forward uh to a summit a
meeting taking place between chairman
kim
and president trump in the not too
distant future before the end of the
year
yes i believe so mr president there is
concern
in the u.s that maybe too much is being
given
up before actual denuclearization is
happening
in north korea how do you address that
there are many skeptical voices as to
whether north korea will actually keep
their promise
this time and however i have to tell you
that
the agreement that we have right now is
actually completely different
from what we had in the past for the
first time in history
you have seen the president of the
united states and the supreme leader of
north korea
threshold an agreement through a summit
meeting and they
made a promise in front of the whole
world to
which is binding and they have lots of
responsibility on their shoulders i
believe that this
promise will be kept in terms of north
korea
they can only have sanctions relief
after denuclearization is completed
and through this they can have the
economic recovery that they are desiring
as for president trump he needs to solve
the north korean nuclear problem
and this is a problem that nobody had
been able to solve in the decades past
so
through this he will be able to have a
major achievement
which is your top priority reunification
or denuclearization my priority is
peace and if we have solid peace then i
believe that
unification will come naturally as well
and
in order to achieve peace the
prerequisite would be
denuclearization what is your
relationship with president trump
and how would you describe him
ever since my inauguration last may i
had
seven summit meetings with president
trump as well as
more than 20 phone calls i can tell you
that
i've become more than a friend with
president trump and between the two of
us
there is absolutely perfect trust and
when you uh
think about what president trump has
accomplished
in terms of north korea's
denuclearization you just have to look
at
the changes that have been in place
during the nine months ever since
last november and if you compare what
president trump said during his speech
at the un general assembly last year
rocket man is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime and
what he'll be saying today tremendous
progress has been made
and i think you're going to see an
outcome then you'll be able to
distinguish the differences and ever
since last november
uh north korea has not been has not
engaged in any nuclear or
missile test and or any provocations of
this kind
and they have already uh permanently
dismantled the nuclear test site in
congedi and this is actually
the only nuclear test site they have
which means that they will not be able
to
have another nuclear test in the future
and during my summit meeting with
chairman kim
in pyongyang last week he also expressed
his willingness to permanently dismantle
uh the missile engine test site and the
launch platform in tong tangi
under observation of american experts
and
when he implements these measures this
will mean that
north korea will not be able to test
long-range missiles again
so now all of this means that north
korea
will not be able to threaten the united
states with
their nuclear or missile arsenal he
is actually willing to take additional
measures
including the dismantlement of the
nuclear
cases and all of this change that we are
witnessing right now
was possible because the
president of the united states decided
to have uh the first
ever summit with the leader of
north korea in 70 years of their history
all of my praise goes to president trump
so you give him a lot of credit
yes you've met with chairman kim more
than
most people in the world
how do you describe him his
sensibilities
is he serious do you really believe that
he could denuclearize his the north
fully or is that something that really
is the identity
of north korea chairman kim
has a great uh has unwavering trust and
expectations for president trump and
uh he is also aware that um the complete
denuclearization
of north korea at such a major feat can
only be achieved by someone like
president trump
so chairman kim actually wants within
to achieve the complete denuclearization
of north korea
with president trump within his first
term in office
and he has expressed this commitment
this desire on many occasions too so in
order to
make progress he wants to have the
second
u.s north korea summit as soon as
possible i would say that
chairman kim is young but he's candid
and he also has clear commitment
to to denuclearization and he is now
ready to abandon his nuclear program
and focus on economic development
instead in order to
help his people he has this kind of a
strategic mind
so um he is looking forward
to achieving complete denuclearization
with president trump
and afterwards receive economic
assistance
do you think that full verifiable
denuclearization the goal of january
2021
that has been talked about is that
realistic
seems like a lot to go in a short period
of time
during my summit meeting in pyongyang
chairman kim
mentioned he is willing to have the
international inspectors
inspect these activities he said that
he's willing to
permanently dismantle the related
facilities in a verifiable way
so i believe that i have ascertained uh
chairman kim's
commitment to a complete
denuclearization uh therefore
um now if north korea
takes a genuine measures in terms of uh
dismantling their nuclear pro
program it all comes down to whether the
united states
is ready to provide corresponding
measures in a swift way
for the united states they promise to
end
its hostile relations with with north
korea to provide
security guarantees and also work
towards new
u.s north korea relations so although
all these actions would not happen
simultaneously
broadly i believe that these actions
need to be taken in parallel
if the united states could provide this
kind of trust i believe that we will be
able to accelerate
the denuclearization process this this
is why i believe that
the denuclearization is achievable
within the first term of president
trump's term do you trust chairman kim
from a u.s perspective he does not have
a great track record of promising and
then
delivering on things
so what we hear from the u.s
administration
is that they would like to see things
done completely
and then pull the sanctions off when we
say corresponding measures
this doesn't only allude to a sanctions
relief
we could think about the declaration to
end the korean war
or humanitarian assist assistance or the
exchanges
uh well the cultural and artistic
exchanges
and such kind of non-political exchanges
so we could think about establishing a a
u.s
liaison office in pyongyang and by
establish
establishing this kind of office we can
show
the u.s commitment to end hostile
relations with north korea
and also logistically support uh the the
activities of the the inspectors and we
could also think about
exchanging economic delegations with
north korea
i can tell you that there is nothing to
lose for us
when we put our trust in north korea and
the measures that north korea will be
taking
will be will be the permanent
dismantlement of
nuclear test site the missile engine
test site
nuclear bases and its existing nuclear
arsenal these
are all irreversible measures however
the measures
the united states and the republic of
korea will be taking would be measures
such as
the suspension of joint military
exercises which can be resumed at any
time
and also the end of war declaration can
be
revoked any time as well if north korea
goes back on its promise then we can put
on these sanctions once again
the united states has nothing to lose do
you envision
seeing one korea in your lifetime
well it is very difficult to predict
when
unification will be achieved we cannot
really plan for this kind of thing
i believe that if we establish complete
peace then we will be able to see one
day
all of a sudden the unification come and
i'm hopeful
that i'll be able to see it within my
lifetime the u.s has had troops on the
korean peninsula for 60 plus years
do you want to see u.s troops leave
sooner rather than later could it
challenge him i would say no
i can tell you that the u.s forces in
korea not only
is beneficial for our deterrence
vis-a-vis north korea
but also it's playing a lynchpin role in
terms of upholding peace and
stability in the northeast asian
region as a whole even after the peace
treaty side and even after unification
is achieved i can see the u.s forces in
korea
remain in place for the as peace and
stability of the north east asian region
you mentioned the end of war
declaration do you expect to sign that
at this next summit with president trump
i had ample discussions with president
trump on this issue
during my summit yesterday and i expect
there will be
plenty of discussions between president
trump and chairman kim
in the upcoming u.s north korea summit
it is
my desire to assign this as soon as
possible
to give a symbol that the
hostile relations between the united
states and north korea have been ended
and i believe that there is a basic
sympathy regarding this view
i want you to address some of your
critics uh
in korea um a couple of
points they say that you've been
clamping down
on journalists and and muzzling north
korean defectors
and your critics say that that you're
undermining free speech there
and and democratic norms how do you
respond to that
yeah well i can tell you that maybe um
out of the entire history of the
republic fair uh the
freedom of speech and the freedom of
press have never been uh greater
than this time and and even uh the kind
of fake news
that you're seeing in among the press
and among the sns
and they go unpunished as well and every
weekend you can see uh in
the uh kuala lumen plaza which is just
right in front of my
uh office you can see um the assemblies
that
heavily criticize me happen every
weekend your critics are their theory is
that you're trying to line south korea
up
with north korea in getting ready for
reunification
to the extent of even taking freedom out
of textbooks
uh not tying it to democracy so you say
in the words of president trump that's
all fake
our news of improving relations with
north korea and
aspiring for unification is actually the
same across
all administrations and the our
constitution
actually prescribes that we need to work
towards
achieving peaceful reunification with
north korea and it is one of the prime
responsibilities
of a president and as for the people who
criticize me
i can tell you that most of them are
people who
in past and administrations had been
calling reunification
as some kind of a bonanza but now they
are turning on me because
the the the government has changed mr
president we appreciate your time
yes thank you